this video is brought to you by
Squarespace from websites and online
stores to marketing tools and analytics
Squarespace is the only one platform to
build a beautiful online presence and
run your business check them out through
the link below more on them in a bit
odor nabanaga hacked out the stones
Toyota hit a Yoshi cut them into shape
and Tokugawa iyasu set them into place
three men of different backgrounds with
vastly different personalities who all
work towards the same goal that many
considered too ambitious to ever be
achieved the complete unification of
Japan today we finish our coverage of
the three great unifiers with a look at
the last member of the trio the one who
actually got to see his dream fulfilled
as he ushered in an entirely New Era for
Japan the founder of the Tokugawa
shogunate Tokugawa yesu
was born on January 31st 1543 at okazaki
Castle in makawa Province during the
turbulent and violent sengoku period of
Japan in case you need a quick reminder
of how things worked in the country back
then let's get up to speed the emperor
was still around but he was a powerless
figurehead who mainly played a
ceremonial role for hundreds of years
Japan had actually been run by a
military leader called a Shogun who
enacted his will through dozens of local
Lords called daimyos but during the
sengoki period even the Shogun had lost
most of his authority by allowing the
daimyos to become too powerful at that
point he needed them more than they
needed him and the Shogun knew that if
some of the strongest diamonds decided
to disobey him there was nothing he
could do about it except whack his
finger in their Direction while giving
them a disappointed look the power
imbalance allowed the daimyos to run
wild as they all poked and prodded their
neighbors in pursuit of power that's
basically what the whole sengoki period
was 150 years of almost constant civil
war between numerous factions with none
of them able to Rise Above the Rest and
claim the Undisputed title all right now
that we're caught up let's get back to
Tokugawa his birth name was actually
matsudaira takachio and he was part of
the matsudaira clan base near modern day
Nagoya as was customary for Japanese
nobleman he changed his name several
times throughout his life but we are
going to stick with Tokugawa from the
start to make this whole video just a
bit less confusing you're welcome
although the matsadira family claimed
descendancy from one of the great clans
of classical Japan by the time Tokugawa
was born they were only a bit player on
the national stage therefore if they
wanted any serious screen time they had
to latch on to someone with more star
power and that someone was imogawa
yoshimoto when Tokugawa was five years
old his father matsudaira hiratada
struck an alliance with the yoshimoto
clan against the Hostile Oda Clan
yoshimoto accepted but his protection
came with a steep price tag Young
Tokugawa would be sent to live with him
at his castle as a hostage just to make
sure that his new ally wouldn't get any
funny ideas about double crossing him
matsudira complied but his son never
made it to yoshimoto the leader of the
odor Clan nobuhide found out about this
little Arrangement and so he laid an
ambush for tokugawa's retinue and took
the nobleman's son hostage for himself
his plan always to force matsadira to
betray yoshimoto or else he would
execute his son but matadira pretty much
told him to go ahead and do it in fact
he'd be doing him a favor because the
sacrifice would show yoshimoto just how
serious he was about their Alliance
whether this was a calculated Bluff or
an attempt to get worse father of the
year we don't know but fortunately for
Tokugawa Oda nabohide spared him and
kept him as a hostage at his castle in
Nagoya for the next few years people
speculate that during this time Tokugawa
met nobahide's son and the man who would
go on to have a tremendous impact on his
life Oda Nobunaga during his years as a
hostage the fighting between Oda and
yoshimoto got more and more intense as
both Clans vied to become the dominant
faction in the same region when Tokugawa
was nine yoshimoto laid Siege to the
casa where he lived and he was given to
yoshimoto as part of a truce between the
two sides now that he had been rescued
and no longer Oz and odeclan hostage the
original Arrangement could resume he
would become a yoshimoto plan hostage
Tokugawa lived at yoshimoto's sunpu
Castle until he came of age but he was
allowed to do all of the stuff that was
expected of a young nobleman he got
married when he was 16 and when his
father died he traveled to the Family
Estate to get confirmed as the new head
of the clan and began raising an army to
fight the Yoda Clan now that he led the
matsudira clan togagawa entered military
service for yoshimoto except that he
would not be fighting Oda nobuhide but
rather the new leader of the clan his
son Odana banaga tokugan was time as a
retainer for yoshimoto had both good and
bad parts the bad part was that he
backed the losing side Nobunaga defeated
yoshimoto at the Battle of okahazama in
1560 and the leader of the yoshimoto
clan was killed in combat the good part
was that Tokugawa himself was nowhere
near that Slaughter having been sent to
capture and hold a fort in a different
part of the province with his former
Master dead Tokugawa considered all of
his previous Oaths null and void wisely
he pledged allegiance to Oda Nobunaga
and together they embarked on a
Countrywide conquering spree they were
determined to bring the whole of Japan
under their sword all right we'll get
back to today's video in just a sec but
first here's a word from today's sponsor
Squarespace look it's easy to get
overwhelmed by the internet there's a
lot of complicated stuff out there web3
blockchain SEO The Internet of Things
what does it all mean who knows who
cares you don't have to worry about it
with Squarespace look contrary to
popular belief you don't have to be a
web engineer to start a website you just
need a good idea and of course
Squarespace Squarespace is the
all-in-one toolkit that helps you
transform that thing that's in your head
onto the screen in front of you
absolutely anyone can use it I know I
did and I don't know a great deal about
making websites look if you're someone
who wants to heavily customize your
website Squarespace gives you the
freedom to do that you could play around
with different elements manipulate the
colors create the exact perfect website
for you but you can also do what I did
just use one of their pre-designed
beautiful templates so that you don't
have to do any design work whatsoever
look and this was particularly useful
for me I have no design skills so look
whether you want to start blog a
business or something in between you
could do it with Squarespace right now
go to squarespace.com for a free trial
and when you're ready Lord you're on
your site go to squarespace.com
biographics just save 10 of your first
purchase of a website or a domain and
now back to today's video
[Music]
now we began tokugawa's 40-year long
journey to become the man in charge
because if there was one quality that he
possessed in Spades it was patience it
probably came from spending most of his
childhood as a hostage but Tokugawa knew
exactly when it was the right time to
step aside and when it was the right
time to strike for now he was eager to
prove himself as nobunaga's worthiest
retainer he started off close to home by
fighting to unite all of mikawa Province
under his Banner this did not prove to
be overly difficult but it was time
consuming Tokugawa could not rely on
reinforcements from Nobunaga for two
reasons while he was too busy with his
own battles and two he expected his
retainers to show that they could stand
and on their own two feet without Daddy
nabanaga coming in to save the day
Tokugawa spent most of the following
decade engaged in combat in makawa in
1567 he received permission from the
emperor to officially change his clan
name to Tokugawa claiming to be a
descendant of the prestigious minamoto
clan that used to include the Imperial
bloodline in centuries past his evidence
was sketchy at best and probably oh
would not have been held up to close
scrutiny but as we said the emperor was
there just for show and since Tokugawa
had Allied himself with the most
dangerous man in Japan who was going to
argue with him in 1568 mikalawa was
under tokugawa's control but he wanted
more so he forged an alliance with
another formidable military commander
Takeda shingen leader of the Takeda Clan
together they started going after the
territories of tokugawa's former boss
imogawa yoshimoto that Union proved to
be remarkably effective and in less than
two years each one had added another
Province to his domain but alliances
were thicker during this turbulent
period of Japanese history that whole
Bushido warrior code saying might as
well have been written on water-soluble
paper for how strictly it was adhered to
with Takeda growing too much in power
Tokugawa plunged the knife into his back
metaphorically speaking and broke their
Alliance he then entered into a new pact
with two of takeda's enemies the usogi
clan and yoshimoto's Son imogawa ujizane
promising to help them conquer takeda's
lands as long as they stayed away from
his newly gained territories Tokugawa
probably intended to [ __ ] the Takeda
Clan permanently not wanting another
powerful faction so close to high but
for now he had to put these Ambitions to
rest because he got the call up from
Nobunaga it was time to gather his army
and join the big leagues because well
they had a country to conquer Tokugawa
and 5 000 of his best men helped odor
Nobunaga defeat the azai and asakura
clans at the Battle of anagawa in 1570
notable not only for featuring the first
ever odor Tokugawa tag team but also for
nobunaga's prodigious use of firearms
which had only been around in Japan for
a few decades at this point it was a
solid start for their Alliance but the
sequel proved to be a complete disaster
for Tokugawa it was like Jaws the
Revenge levels of bad that we're talking
about here Takeda did not take his
betrayal lying down so in 1572 he
gathered a large army and marched into
tokugawa's territory intending to
capture his main castle at hamamatsu
their battle took place in January 1573
outside of hamamatsu at mikatagahara
Tokugawa had around 8 000 men plus
another 3 000 from Oda Takara shingen
had tripled that including a very strong
Cavalry plus nobody would deny that he
was the superior military strategist
given the 20-year age gap between him
and his enemy Takeda ignored tokugawa's
forces at first sending his Vanguard to
hit oda's troops and hit him hard and
fast chaos ensued among nobunaga's
forces and they quickly retreated
leaving Tokugawa on his own then
Superior numbers allowed to cater to
bring back his first line and let them
rest while others entered The Fray
against okagawa's Army it was an
absolute bloodbath and tokugawa's forces
were wiped out completely according to a
tradition he returned to hamamatic
castle with only five men it was without
a doubt the most conclusive and
humiliating loss the tokagawa would ever
experience but somehow he still managed
to survive and hold his castle whether
that was dumblr clever strategy or
divine intervention you'd be the judge
so as to avoid a full-on panic inside
hamamatsu Tokugawa ordered the complete
procedure for his rotating Army castle
gate left wide open Brad is lit War
drums beating the whole shebang even
though the retreating Army could fit
inside a mid-sized family Sudan when
takeda's troops arrived at hamamatsu and
saw the spectacle they suspected they
might be walking into a trap so instead
of charging the almost defenseless
Castle right away they decided to make
Camp during the night a small band of
Tokugawa Soldiers infiltrated the camp
and launched a surprise attack causing
confusion among the enemy ranks Takeda
feared that Tokugawa might have some
trick up his sleeve he had not foreseen
and that reinforcements from nabanaga
might trap his forces between two armies
and even though he had completely
annihilated his foe he played it safe
and lifted The Siege and retreated back
to his own territory Takeda shingen
fully intended to try again later but
that opportunity never came he was
injured in another battle and died just
a couple of months later leaving his
clan in the not so capable hands of his
son to cater katsuyori who was
definitely not a chip of the old block
he lacked his father's experience and
skill and was soundly defeated by the
combined forces of Nobunaga and takagawa
at the Battle of nagashino in 1575. he
lived for another six years after that
launching minor incursions against his
enemies but the Takeda Clan was no
longer a serious threat to oda's
Ambitions over the coming years Tokugawa
redeemed his humiliation at mikitagahara
and became one of nobunaga's most
trusted advisors we're not going to go
into every battle here because we did
that for our odor nabanaga bio which is
just sitting there in case you're
interested the short of it is that Oda
had completely overthrown the Shogun
atom was on his way to uniting Japan
when he was portrayed in 1582 and
assassinated in what became known as the
honoji incident with Oda Nobunaga gone
the new question arose who would take
his place
there was a large power vacuum left by
uda's death and unsurprisingly several
people rushed to fill it even though
there was only room for one a patient
and cautious man dokugawa was not one of
them even though Nobunaga had already
designated his Heir his eldest son
nobotada he had died alongside his
father at hono G so the warlord's former
daimyos were divided over who should
take the reins Tokugawa understood that
things were about to get chaotic and
violent and that he would have to tread
carefully if he wanted to keep his head
let alone remain in his position of
power ultimately though he had to make a
choice and he threw his support behind
Oda nobokatsu nobunaga's eldest
surviving son however it soon became
evident that he had hitched his horse to
the wrong wagon as toyotomi hiroyoshi
nobunaga's strongest General was
emerging as the odds-on favorite to
claim the crown on paper hiriyoshi was
supporting nobunaga's grandson hidden
Nobu to assume control of the Yoda Clan
but since the grandson was still in
diapers everyone understood that hidey
Yoshi would be the one cooling the shot
and he had a lot of support too from
other plans but now that Tokugawa made
his choice it was stuck with it an
inevitable conflict arose between the
two sides which met in battle several
times during the kamaki campaign in 1584
but neither group could score a decisive
win and each man recognized that
eliminating the other one permanently
would have been a costly and bloody
Endeavor that would leave him vulnerable
to his enemies therefore hideyoshi and
Tokugawa sat down at the negotiating
table and reached a compromise Tokugawa
withdrew his support of nobukatsu and
formally agreed to become a vassal of
hideyoshi and in exchange he was given
command of five provinces and left to
his own devices since Tokugawa was the
last thorn in hideyoshi's side his
submission made it official that
toyotomi was Now The Man In Charge no
more hiding behind nabanagas progeny and
pretending that the odor Clan was still
running things the toyotomi clan had
taken over hideyoshi ruled for a decade
and a half picking up when obanaga left
off and continuing the conquest of Japan
if you want before picture do check out
the bio we did on him but while all of
this was going on Tokugawa was busy in
his little corner of the world as we
said he was a patient man and he knew
that tayatomi wouldn't rule forever in
1590 the Hojo clan in the Kanto region
of Japan was the last major holdout he
had to submit to hit a Yoshi so he
invaded and for the first time he
requested tokugawa's help the two of
them made short work of their enemies
and as a reward hideyoshi granted
Tokugawa the eight provinces that he had
just conquered from the hoji clan in
exchange for the five he already
controlled in central Japan now eight is
greater than five so on paper this was
indeed a reward since Tokugawa would
gain a lot of new territories however he
also had to relocate from an area where
he was well established one where he had
no traditional connections which was
also much further away from toyotomi's
capital of Osaka in reality the move was
probably a clever way for hideyoshi to
limit his vassal's power without giving
him any reason to complain in the end
Tokugawa accepted since refusing it
would have meant war with hideyoshi
again and he chose as his new head
caught as the small town of Edo which
would later become better known as Tokyo
most of what we said so far painted
Hiroshi as a shrewd and calculating
strategist but in the completely chucked
that image in the bin during the 1590s
with two disastrous invasions of Korea
wisely Tokugawa managed to stay away
from that hot mess completely and spent
those years consolidating his power in
his new region in 1598 toyotomy fell ill
and established the Council of five
Elders who was supposed to rule his
Regents until his young son hirayori
came of age he died soon after and
Tokugawa decided that he had waited long
enough it had been 38 years since he
first pledged himself to Odana banaga
now he was older and wiser he controlled
the best organized territory and
commanded the strongest army in Japan it
was finally time
[Music]
the other four Elders proved more loyal
to toyotomi so in order for Tokugawa to
assume power he had to take all of them
out conveniently one of them died of
natural causes less than a year later so
one down three to go weirdly enough even
though the other Elders all rallied
their armies against okagawa his biggest
threat was a fourth daimyo named Ishida
mitsunari even though toyotomi didn't
see fit to include him in his little
Council mitsunari was a skilled
commander who was the one to actually
lead boots on the ground against
Tokugawa the conflict wasn't some
drawn-out Affair that went on for years
and years quite the opposite in fact the
result was pretty much decided in a
single battle that lasted for only a few
hours October 21st 1600 the little
village called Seka gahara in central
hondtru ball witness to one of the most
defining battles in Japanese history as
both sides gathered the bulk of their
armies and just went to town on each
other it was a resounding victory for
Tokugawa as a large portion of the enemy
forced affected to his side after he
promised them leniency as well as
generous rewards should he become the
new leader of Japan and that was exactly
what happened matanari and several other
prominent daimyos who were local to
toyotomi were captured and executed days
later as per the remaining Elders two of
them surrendered to Tokugawa following
the loss of sekigahara they were spared
their lives and even allowed to continue
serving as daimyos although their
Holdings were substantially reduced the
third went into hiding and he managed to
elude Tokugawa for a few years he too
was fed the death penalty when he was
found and instead was simply exiled with
nobody left to offer any resistance to
utakagawa he took the opportunity to
completely overhaul the power structure
of Japan he was sitting at the top of
course and he radically redistributed
the land in a way he saw fit some loyal
Clans gained a lot of territory and
influence overnight others were neutered
by losing most of their land while some
Clans which Tokugawa considered
implacable or wiped out completely the
toyotomy clan was allowed to stick
around for now and even believe it to
remain at Osaka Castle but with greatly
reduced territory everyone was at
tokugawa's Mercy so in 1603 he decided
to make it official he went to the
emperor and had himself appointed as the
new Shogun of Japan triggering the start
of the Tokugawa shogunate the military
government that would rule the country
for the next
265 years until the emergence of
Imperial Japan in modern times he had
finished the job that Oda Nobunaga and
toyotomi Hiroshi had started which is
why the three of them are known as
Japan's great unifiers even though it
wasn't exactly or what you would call a
team effort the Tokugawa was 60 years
old by the time he had finally assumed
control and being Shogun was a young
man's game that's why he retired just
two years later and named his son
hidatado as the new Shogun but don't be
fooled tokugawa's word was still the law
regardless of his title the reason he
did this was to ensure a smooth
transition of power while he was still
alive and avoid the mistakes made by Oda
and toyotomi and speaking of toetomi the
clan was now led by hideyoshi's original
Heir his son hiriyori although at first
okagawa spared him he had second
thoughts as the boy grew up into a young
man who still commanded the Loyalty of
some daimyos who considered him the
rightful ruler Tokugawa decided to put a
definitive end to such silly Notions and
laid Siege to Osaka Castle in 1615
killing hadayori and his family
afterward the Shogun dissolved the
toyotomi clan showing everyone else that
he was absolutely ruthless when it came
to threats to his authority bonam
tokugawa's best efforts as Shogun was to
oversee major construction projects at
Ido transforming of a settlement from a
village into a burgeoning metropolis
that serves today as the heart of Japan
hence why the Tokugawa shogunate is
commonly referred to as the Edo period
tokugawa's feelings towards foreigners
changed with the years at first he was
happy with the trade they brought in
especially those fancy aquabases and
other firearms that proved invaluable in
his quest to become Shogun but he had a
change of heart towards the end of his
life he became particularly wary of all
the Christians who came to his country
to proselytize so he put us on on halt
to their efforts by expelling all
Catholic missionaries from the country
in 1614. from then on he placed his
country on a path of isolationism that
Japan maintained for Centuries with his
rule firmly secure and his clan at the
head of the entire country Tokugawa yasu
considered his mission finally
accomplished he died on June the first
1616 age 73 and was defined as tosho
daigonan or great deity of the East
Shining Light